die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna paradies guten abend und
herzlich willkommen an meiner seite für
den sport norbert könig schule genommen
und wir schauen nach afghanistan
angesichts der dramatischen lage dort
unsere wichtigen themen
kabul im visier der taliban die
islamisten kommen der afghanischen
hauptstadt immer näher die
bundesregierung berät über eine
rettungsaktion
wahlkampfauftakt der spd beflügelt von
steigenden umfragewerten starten die
sozialdemokraten in die heiße phase vor
der bundestagswahl
verheerende waldbrände in russland seit
wochen zerstören riesige feuer in
sibirien wald und buschland
umweltschützer schlagen alarm über
ein großteil afghanistans hat nicht mehr
die kontrolle sondern die taliban jetzt
hat sich der afghanische präsident
ashraf ghani nach langem schweigen in
einer fernsehansprache zu wort gemeldet
barnier rief zum kampf gegen die
islamisten auf und kündigte an die armee
an neu zu mobilisieren denn die scheint
den taliban bisher nicht viel entgegen
zu setzen ohne große gegenwehr erobern
die islamisten eine provinz nach der
anderen und rücken immer weiter auf die
hauptstadt zu die taliban trennen
offenbar nur noch wenige dutzend
kilometer von kabul
südwestlich der hauptstadt liegt auch
die strategische wichtige stadt ghasni
dort haben die taliban bereits das sagen
katrin eigendorf
sie scheinen sich sicher zu fühlen
taliban-kämpfer am straßenrand in ghazni
unser zdf kamera man darf in der
provinzmetropole filmen in der die
islamisten die macht übernommen haben
mit amerikanischen haben wie die die
armee zurückgelassen hat fahren sie
durch die stadt in einem sportstadion
haben sie nach eigenen angaben 300
soldaten gefangen alle hätten sich
widerstandslos ergeben behaupten die
kämpfer und kündigen an
ganz afghanistan und alle muslime werden
unter die kontrolle der taliban kommen
die verwaltung wird ihre arbeit
aufnehmen und das system des islamischen
emirats wird im ganzen land kommen so
gott will
in kabuls gut gesicherten botschafts und
regierungsviertel laufen die
vorbereitungen für den ernstfall immer
mehr länder auch deutschland ziehen
botschaftspersonal ab präsident ashraf
ghani wendet sich heute mit einer
botschaft an sein volk pro series jg in
der aktuellen situation ist die re
integration unserer sicherheits und
verteidigungsrechte unsere priorität da
muss für das scheitern der armee machen
immer mehr afghanen den präsidenten
verantwortlich forderungen nach seinem
rücktritt wachsen die afghanische
regierung hat nicht nur moralisch ihre
glaubwürdigkeit verloren sie hatten
nicht einmal einen charismatischen
führer sie haben diesen krieg
entsetzlich schlecht gemanagt und die
resultate sehen wir jetzt
ein rücktritt des afghanischen
präsidenten es scheint nur eine frage
der zeit dass ashraf ghani dem druck
nachgibt
bäckern flieht aus afghanistan die grüne
kanzlerkandidat in bernburg fordert dass
sich die eu auf die steigende zahl von
flüchtlingen vorbereitet mit klaren
kontingent regeln auch zahlreiche
deutsche sowie afghanische ortskräfte
sind noch im land bei der
bundesregierung gab es heute eine
krisentelefon sitzung dazu wie man sie
schnell in sicherheit bringen kann
patrizia wiedemeier
heute morgen im kanzleramt krisensitzung
kanzlerin merkel beriet sich telefonisch
mit einigen ministern und ministerinnen
hinterher hieß es schnellstmöglich wolle
man mit hilfe der bundeswehr afghanische
ortskräfte sowie mitarbeiter der
deutschen botschaft und von
hilfsorganisationen
zurückholen viel zu spät der spd
außenminister hätte sich früher kümmern
müssen kritisierte daraufhin cdu
kanzlerkandidat laschet
seit monaten prüft das auswärtige amt
wie man denn ortskräfte da herausholen
könnte mit tausenden bedenken so rum und
so um hin und her das hilft jetzt nichts
mehr die taliban sind nicht weit weg von
kabul die bundeswehr muss diese menschen
retten das ist unsere moralische
verpflichtung nach allem was sie für uns
leistet haben rückführen ja aber auch
der vormarsch der taliban müsse gestoppt
werden fordert der vorsitzende des
auswärtigen ausschusses röttgen die nato
hat eine verantwortung die amerikaner
haben eine verantwortung auch wie hey
meiner verantwortung dafür und wir
sollten auch das was wir dann leisten
können hilfe auch anbieten ob es
logistik ist medizinische versorgung
material für die künstler kandidatin der
grünen baerbock vorläufig kein thema sie
fordert die sofortige evakuierung die
bundesregierung handele zu spät jetzt
geht es darum die auswirkungen nämlich
dass menschen um ihr leben fürchten
müssen weil sie die bundeswehr
unterstützt haben auszufliegen und das
muss die deutsche bundesregierung tun
und einen cdu-außenpolitiker sollte die
deutsche bundesregierung dazu drängen
wirklich diese aufgabe jetzt endlich
anzugehen die verteidigungsministerin
ließ verlauten einsatzbereite kräfte der
bundeswehr für eine schnellstmögliche
rückführung stünden bereit der deutsche
bundestag soll an diesen entscheidungen
beteiligt werden mehr details wurden
heute nicht genannt
truppenabzug offensive der taliban in
unserer zdf heute können sie sich eine
chronologie der ereignisse in
afghanistan anschauen
und wir kommen nach deutschland wo die
spd heute in bochum ihre heiße
wahlkampfphase eingeläutet hat auf 19
prozent kommt die partei im aktuellen
zdf-politbarometer ein plus dümpelte die
spd doch lange bei um die 15 prozent
herum vor allem kanzlerkandidat scholz
kommt in umfragen derzeit gut an besser
als unionskandidat laschet und
grünen-kandidat in bernburg das bunt
sagt berichtet
bochum hier tief im westen startet die
spd in den wahlkampf im einstigen
stammland der sozialdemokratie zeigt die
partei neues selbstbewusstsein
die umfragen machen sowohl dem
kanzlerkandidaten als auch der basis mut
wir können das schaffen es ist das erste
mal seit vier monaten dass er wirklich
hoffnung haben können den kanzler zu
stellen ein gutes programm wir haben
guten kandidaten läuft läuft vor allem
für ihn olaf scholz zieht in den
umfragen die spd noch nicht wirklich
kandidat partei und programm sollen ab
jetzt eine einheit bilden wir können die
zukunft gestalten wir müssen uns vor ihr
nicht fürchten und wir sozialdemokraten
sozialdemokraten haben dafür einen guten
plan scholz stärker hat auch mit dem
schwächeln der politischen konkurrenz zu
tun die nutzt der kanzlerkandidat für
seine attacken eine weitere von cdu csu
geführte bundesregierung kostet
deutschland wohlstand arbeitsplätze und
zukunft das darf nicht sein scholz
fordert immer wieder respekt und den
zusammenhalt der gesellschaft dafür
brauche es ein mindestlohn von 12 euro
sozial gerechten klimaschutz und
bezahlbares wohnen
das gehört doch dazu wenn man ein gutes
leben führen will dass man sich die
eigene wohnung leisten kann das auch
eine normale arbeitnehmern ein normaler
arbeitnehmer doch noch mal die
perspektive hat sich vielleicht ein
kleines häuschen ab zu sparen 44 tage
noch bis zur bundestagswahl
44 tage in denen die spd den wahlkampf
komplett auf olaf scholz zuschneidet
seine umfragewerte sollen die partei
nach oben ziehen
und wir schauen ins ausland haiti eines
der ärmsten länder der welt wurde in den
letzten jahren bereits von
naturkatastrophen heimgesucht jetzt hat
die erde wieder gebebt im süden des
karibikstaates mit stärke 7,2 die
behörden sprechen bislang von mindestens
29 toten der ministerpräsident nennt die
schäden massiv augenzeugen berichten
dass menschen unter eingestürzten
häusern begraben wurden die us
geologiebehörde befürchtet in haiti
hunderte tote
in russland gibt es seit monaten
verheerende waldbrände mehr als 250
feuer zerstören laut offiziellen angaben
die dichten wälder des landes es brennt
auf einer fläche so groß wie die schweiz
besonders betroffen ist jakutien im
osten sibiriens im winter einer der
kältesten regionen russlands
umweltschützerinnen schlagen seit langem
alarm und schätzen das ausmaß der
brandkatastrophe als historisch ein für
begann berichtet
seit wochen wüten die feier in jakutien
oftmals nur mit schaufeln und schläuchen
ausgestattet versuchen freiwillige die
feuerwehr zu unterstützen
wir haben nur 21 leute auf 25
quadratkilometern so ist es unmöglich
ein ausbreiten der feuer zu verhindern
der klimawandel lässt sibiriens wälder
im sommer austrocknen jeder funke jeder
blitzeinschlag kann so einen
flächenbrand entfachen russlands
behörden bestimmen zudem areale in denen
der wald ungestört brennen darf weil sie
fernab der zivilisation sind löschen zu
teuer wäre nur die feuer halten sich
nicht an diese grenzen erreichen immer
öfter ortschaften und dann sind da noch
die budgetkürzungen die russische
forstwirtschaft stimmt uns zu das für
die zwecke der feuerbekämpfung 100
milliarden rubel investiert werden
müssten doch in der tat werden ihr nur
noch 36 milliarden zugewiesen
jacobi entsteht auf permafrost die feuer
lassen das eis schmelzen das gibt methan
frei was den klimawandel weiter anheizen
wird auch andere teils giftige gase
treten ausmachen das atmen in der
landeshauptstadt schwer
aus der ja nicht wusste ständig meine
augen und mein kopfschmerzen den alten
leuten geht es noch schlechter
präsident putin erklärte heute die
naturkatastrophen die russland dieses
jahr erschüttern seien beispiellos der
klimawandel müsse systematisch
angegangen werden für die brennenden
regionen kommt diese erkenntnis zu spät
sie hoffen auf ausgiebigen regen
die menschen in spanien sind was heiße
sommer angeht ja einiges gewohnt aber
derzeit ist es besonders heiß in vielen
gebieten zeigten die thermometer
deutlich über 40
rad an vor allem im zentrum aber auch im
süden des landes etwa in andalusien wie
die menschen in sevilla damit umgehen
berichtet anna und
sightseeing in sevilla zur maske kommt
der fächer als unverzichtbares
accessoire dass es in andalusien heiß
wird das hatten die touristen hier vor
den palastanlagen erwartet doch nicht
eine solche hitzewelle von 45 grad und
mehr
manchmal fällt das atmen schwer wir
kommen aus belgien da hat es sehr viel
geregnet der kontrast dazu jetzt ist
ziemlich beeindruckend
[Musik]
wasser wird über lebenswichtig in den
straßen und auf den plätzen verteilen
freiwillige helfer der stadt getränke
denn selbst den hitze erprobten spanien
bereiten diese temperaturen sorgen
natürlich gab es solch extreme
temperaturen auch schon mal in der
vergangenheit aber wir können unsere
augen nicht mehr davor verschließen dass
die hitzewellen auf den klimawandel
zurückzuführen sind
zur hitze kommt eine grosse trockenheit
fast im ganzen land herrscht weit
brandgefahr förster patroullieren in den
nationalparks
das wetterphänomen ist vergleichbar mit
der situation wie wir sie in
griechenland oder der türkei erlebt
haben auch hier besteht die gefahr dass
sich feuer ausbreiten
leichte abkühlung ist für die nächste
woche angekündigt doch meteorologen
warnen dass spanien künftig öfter mit
solch extremen hitzewelle rechnen muss
in frankreich haben auch an diesem
wochenende zehntausende gegen die
aktuelle corona politik der regierung
protestiert
dabei richtet sich die wut der
demonstrierenden vor allem gegen die
impfpflicht im gesundheitswesen und den
gesundheitspass diesen brauchen die
menschen in frankreich an öffentlichen
orten um nachzuweisen dass sie geimpft
genesen oder getestet sind landesweit
rechnen die behörden mit rund
250.000 demonstrieren dann
schauen wir auf die wichtigen corona
zahlen in deutschland das robert koch
institut registrierte
5644 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
das sind
2438 mehr als vor einer woche elf
menschen starben in verbindung mit 19
innerhalb eines tages die sieben tage
incidents steigt auf jetzt
32,7
langsam kommen die aufräumarbeiten in
den flutgebieten vorne
nordrhein-westfalen und rheinland-pfalz
voran im art teil zum beispiel sind
jetzt alle orte über das straßennetz
zumindest notdürftig wieder erreichbar
aber an vielen orten stellt sich die
frage ob alle zerstörten häuser
überhaupt wieder aufgebaut werden können
gerade auch die denkmalgeschützten
alexander resch
bad münstereifel hart getroffen von der
flut mehr als 200 denkmalgeschützte
häuser hier sind schwer beschädigt auch
der besitz von familie esser sie hatten
gerade renoviert tochter christina
sollte hier einziehen dann kam die flut
das eben in der dritten generation
sozusagen in familienbesitz und eine
herzensangelegenheit
wir wurden vorher schon für verrückt
erklärt es überhaupt anzupacken
wir haben auch nicht unbegrenzt geld zur
verfügung insofern sind wir sehr stark
auf staatliche hilfen angewiesen
berückend fachwerkhäuser renaissance
bauten es wird millionen kosten die
schäden zu beseitigen manches wird nicht
zu retten sein zur not müsse man
fassaden rekonstruieren so die nrw
ministerin wenn sie zum beispiel die
stadtsilhouette von bad münstereifel
nehmen die ist vom pittoreske geprägt so
und dies vielfach jetzt angegriffen da
wird es auch häuser geben die
möglicherweise nicht stehen bleiben
können und dann setzen wir doch nicht
ernsthafter weise ein funktional bau aus
dem 21sten jahrhundert dazwischen also
ja ich bin offen für rekonstruktion doch
was wenn wir an der aa ganze
häuserzeilen zerstört sind der
wiederaufbau von historie habe grenzen
sagen kritiker weil man eigentlich auch
nicht wegretuschieren sollte dass hier
etwas passiert ist etwas das ja auch
tragisch ist dem menschen ihr leben
verloren haben das ja auch als letzte
warnung der natur vielleicht verstanden
werden kann an uns und man nicht so tun
als könnte man zurück in eine idyllische
vergangenheit bad münstereifel soll
wieder auferstehen in alter pracht doch
überall wird das nicht möglich sein
auch in der türkei kämpfen die menschen
gegen hochwasser an während sich der
süden erst langsam von den schweren
waldbränden erholt leidet der norden
seit tagen unter verheerenden
überschwemmungen mindestens 44 menschen
kamen dabei ums leben mehr als 2000
mussten ihre häuser verlassen
heftige regenfälle hatten die
flutkatastrophe am mittwoch ausgelöst
wir kommen jetzt zum sport und der
fußball bundesliga gab es für die beiden
aufsteiger gar nicht zu holen nahmen
beide staaten auswärts und bleiben noch
ohne punkte besonders bitter gerät die
rückkehr nach acht jahren zweite liga
für die spielvereinigung greuther fürth
beim vfb stuttgart kassieren die franken
direkt mal fünf gegentore ebelings
treffer zum 15 ist nur noch
ergebniskorrektur die stuttgarter sind
trotzdem zumindest vorläufig erster
tabellenführer der neuen saison dicht
gefolgt von hoffenheim mit derselben
tordifferenz 14 0 sieger beim fc
augsburg der verbuchung beginnt nach dem
siebten aufstieg mit einer 0 1
niederlage beim vfl wolfsburg dazu zwei
unentschieden union berlin und bayer
leverkusen trennten sich 1 zu 1 keine
tore in bielefeld bei null zu null der
arminia gegen den sc freiburg am abend
spielt borussia dortmund gegen eintracht
frankfurt gestern mönchengladbach gegen
bayern münchen 1 1 2 spielen morgen das
aktuelle sportstudio um 23 uhr mit dem
abendspiel dortmund gegen frankfurt zu
gast bei katrin müller-hohenstein sind
zwei olympiasiegerinnen weitspringerin
malakka wie hamburg und dressurreiterin
jessica von bredow bernd
20 eineinhalb jahre nach gründung der
deutschen fußball liga wird erstmals
eine frau den chefsessel übernehmen die
medien expertin donata hopfen wird
bereits zum jahreswechsel nachfolgerin
von christian seifert der seit 2005
vorsitzender der geschäftsführung ist
laura philipp ist neue triathlon
europameisterin über die allman distanz
die 34 jährige heidelbergerin kam in
kuopio in finnland nach acht stunden und
38 eineinhalb minuten ins ziel
das ist ein überlegener sieg der
deutschen laura findet 21 minuten vor
der zweitplatzierten im ziel schon auf
der 3,8 kilometer lange schwimmstrecke
war sie mit an der spitze auf der rat
distanz über 180,2 kilometern bildete
sie ein spitzen trio mit der
amerikanerin mccauley und immer gen
simmons aus der schweiz die schliesslich
zweiter und dritter wurden bei marathon
hatte sie schon nach fünf kilometern
mehr als drei minuten vorsprung den sie
immer weiter ausbaute hinter der
siegerin laura philipp drei weitere
deutsche triathleten unter die besten
zehn profis
für julia sude und karla borger hat es
in wien nicht zum em-titel gereicht
immerhin können sich die
beachvolleyballerinnen nacholympische
enttäuschung über bronze freuen
tropische temperaturen und partystimmung
in wien den ersten satz im kleinen
finale dominieren und gewinnen die
beiden letten anastasia krafts nok und
china grau dina doch karla borger und
julia sude kämpfen sich beeindruckend
zurück sichern sich den zweiten
durchgang mit 21 zu 17
vor allem taktisch wird das spiel der
düsseldorferin immer besser matchball im
dritten satz verwandelt 15 zu 8 bronze
für karla borger und julia sude bei der
beachvolleyball em
das wars vom wiener strand dann genau
was und jetzt kommen wir noch zu einem
mysteriösen rätsel an der britischen
nordsee küste und seine auflösung dort
waren nämlich gleich mehrere spray
bilder aufgetaucht alle im stil von
banksy dem anonym street art künstler
und alle an urlaubsorten dienten schon
bessere tage gesehen haben heute dann
die bestätigung ja ich war es in einer
art making of zeigt sich banksy sogar
beim reisen und sprang zumindest ein
bisschen sommerliche urlaubsgrüße einmal
anlass
und apropos sommermorgen ist das wetter
dreigeteilt eher wolkig mit etwas regen
einfach nur sommerlich oder schwül heiß
und gewittrig genaueres dazu hat gleich
katja horneffer für sie um 22 uhr 45
begrüßt die marietta slomka mit dem
heute-journal und wir sagen auf
wiedersehen machen sie es gut
[Musik]
bleibt das wetter ändert sich der
einfluss von hoch elfi wird immer
geringer und zwischen den tiefs luciano
und kurt kommt deutlich kühlere luft
heran da sind auch wolken dabei und da
kommt auch etwas regen mit das war schon
heute so an der grenze zu dänemark gab
es einige regenschauer sonst aber
überwog doch der sonnenschein und so
kletterten die temperatur und zumeist
auf 25 bis 32 grad und nur unter den
dichteren wolken im norden gibt es bei
20 grad kühler auch heute nacht ist es
meist nur sehr gering bewölkt im norden
sind die wolken dichter bringen etwas
regen mit und die temperaturen sinken am
alpenrand hier an der donau oder auch am
oberrhein auf 18 grad kühler wird zur
maschinen sauerland mit zehn grad und
morgen liegen die höchsttemperaturen
einen küsten von nord- und ostsee bei 20
21 grad sonst werden es 25 bis 28 grad
im süden und südwesten wird es schwül
heiß mit 29 bis 32 grad und das wetter
ist morgen dreigeteilt für die meisten
gibt das einfach nur einen schönen
sommertag im norden gibt es wieder die
dichteren wolken mit etwas regen und im
süden da kann es dann am nachmittag eng
begrenzt durchaus lokal für umwelt
erreichen für kräftige gewitter mit
hagel platzregen und sturmböen in der
neuen woche kommt dann die kaltfront die
wird das wetter komplett durch rütteln
dann lägen die temperaturen nur noch bei
16 bis 21 grad am dienstag guten abend